so remember they've been a little bit
naughty and forgot to define this and by
the way don't say it's a cool question I
love it it's like oh wow this really
happened and I can work out exactly
what's happening with the forces they
tell you that the wind is exalting that
exudes order exerting their force of all
point 9 mutants okay so for my 9 ends
are going that way you also know i think
they tell you what is it mass mass one
kilogram right one kilogram yeah so
you've got 9.8 meters going that way so
now all the remains is to say well
because these guys are acting this way
and the only thing counteracting like
making that look fly off making it
simple is this string what they even
call from where these two must be equal
and opposite just my pleasure of
attention is true okay so therefore I'm
going to put it in on some other colors
because like I said these diagrams get
very busy very fast you can see over
here right ah Thank You venison name to
you I think I called that album and call
this novel so that's how far then what
you can do is create around here this
diagram is simple enough
this area is simple enough that i'm
going to put the arm i'm going to
resolve the forces on the diagram rather
than draw a separate one you can see
before by the way why I had to do it
because like there's so many forces here
vertical forces going to be overlapping
the charges confusing but here I just
got this sorry going up that's vertical
okay which must be equal opposite to
this and then you've got this guy acting
this way which must equal opposite to
that okay because they must balance out
so you can see when you have a look at
what weights now from this okay well
here's our fight inside right it's the
same angle of depression all the way
along what are we going to use to help
it actually work out without for tears
flow provision it's okay yes it's going
to be the missions right so you can see
you've got going in this direction it
must be four point nine in Newton's also
going in that right Detroit yeah and you
also got back pointing on that way like
so okay so therefore probably what I
would formally right is i'm going to
write again pair of equations that
relate tea and our fights to these two
vectors ok so I'm going to say T sine
alpha what's that come on Simon that's
better for right thank you nine point
eight neutrons in the same way T cos
alpha is going to be then for you and so
to get 10 alpha that's what they're
Arthur clearly all I need to do is
divide one by two so 10 alpha is equal
to two and that's where they get your
angle for okay now what do you think is
the quickest path out of these two
equations to get to team yeah thank you
so because you've got a sign here
cosine here I don't want any offers in
this expression right so if this is one
and two then I'm going to add the
squares of these right so my left hand
side I'm going to get T squared sine
squared plus 2t squared cos square right
and then over here now this is a bit
sneaky because when you look you like ah
the question is gone back to geez they
do that anyway therefore this is G and
this is half g right so therefore G
square and half g so that's a plus half
g will square does that make sense
yippee so over here what happens on the
left-hand side don't skip that step this
is T squared outside off and then I will
let that equal to one in a second this
is G squared plus what so now I've got T
squared five-on-four g square so now you
take the square root which gives you
root 5 on to cause you don't mind it to
be yes that's exactly what would you use
inverse like you a triangle using my oh
yeah here you could do that too because
like you're trying to find we're just
trying to find this thing yeah so that
that's fine I prefer this way of doing
it because it shows ok I student
understands how to make these forces
interact with each other and you're
always going to get every single time
you get the side and you get the cosine
so if you are trying to put them back
together then just square out in some
senses we have done the same thing
because I'm doing Pythagoras just like
you want
this 4.93 I think that's okay this
particular question has videos much
wrong in leaving this not in terms of GM
I think it's just convenient because
like oh this is nice and neat versus
yeah she's showing me um so yeah it's
fine okay